[موسيقى]
السعوديه
لانها مكان للفنانين والعيش معهم رائع جدا
فهم اشخاص مضيافونا ومنفتحون جدا وحلمي ان
اعرف الفن والثقافه العربيه الى شعب
ليتوانيا وادمجها بمنهج جمهوريه اوزوبيس
اود ابراز الثقافه اليمنيه واكون واجهه
لليمن احلم بتقديم تلك الثقافه الى
الجمهور فنحن هنا ليس فقط لكي ناخذ وانما
ايضا لكي نعطي في المقابل بالنسبه الي
الفن هو اللغه المشتركه بين البشر من
اليسير جدا ان يتخطب الناس بلغه الفن اتوق
حقا الى اظهار ما يمكنني ان اسهم فيه
[موسيقى]
ذهبت مرتين الى شكاكو بدعوه من الجليه كما
زرت نيويورك وفرنسا اذ لدي اصول فرنسيه
بعيده ذهبت ايضا الى المانيا لمعرض فني
لكنها كانت فتره مرعبه اثناء الجائحه زرت
اماكن عده لكنني اعمله هنا